and you know how like when you're
recording you lose track of time and
you're in the zone and she goes man that
was a hot cake I love that and she goes
oh damn the anesthesia is wearing off oh
[__] waking up and you wake up ah my
guts and everything
[Music]
a plastic surgeon from Ohio and then
somebody going to Ohio recently I'm I'm
going to Ohio oh yeah you are uh didn't
you just come back from Ohio or
something nope why why are you going
there one of the Cleveland Cleveland
Clinic
what's that mean me and my wife we going
to Cleveland why are you representing so
hard for a medical center they're pretty
good they're pretty good what they do
apparently they're pretty top-notch bro
people for her leg good luck guys thanks
appreciate it good luck yeah appreciate
the Vibes yeah so this plastic surgeon
from Ohio I don't know from the
Cleveland Clinic but from Ohio
what is the now this is Ohio it's just
number one
it's actually two
uh has been banned from practicing
medicine after streaming botched
surgeries on Tick Tock oh like like his
own butt surgeries her like publishing
her messing up and she doesn't even know
that she's breaking it down like this is
what I did wrong and she's pointing at
like I think she's just I think just the
general practice of streaming surgeries
yeah you know what I mean like in the
middle of a surgery is already like oh
in the middle yeah you have to go
against the law probably it's probably
like so she's been stripped of her
medical license and permanently banned
from practicing in the state after
streaming allegedly botched procedures
on Tick Tock
um quote the Ohio Medical Board
uh voted to ban Catherine grob also
known as Dr Roxy in her plastic surgery
practice quote Roxy plastic surgery and
to her many Tick Tock followers from
ever practicing again in the state the
board said grah who originally had her
license suspended in November neglected
her patients as she live streamed parts
of their procedures spoke into a camera
and answered viewer questions so she
just left them there they're just like
sedated and [__] faces halfway like
done and they're botched all right we're
gonna talk to our donators now oh my God
what's up Chad how you doing chat yeah
just in the middle of the surgery and
then they go back to finishing the face
all done [__] crazy but
but even as I just feel that classic
surgery in this country has always been
messed up but nobody really cared they
know it's like everybody says oh Michael
Jackson did something on his face but
nobody was says you know who did this
terrible job job on Michael Jackson you
think it's a terrible job oh yeah of
course
oh you think it's good me and Joe me and
Joe are big Michael Jackson fans so we
go like I think he looks more like Peter
Pan
that then he yeah I think that's his
goal he wanted to look like Peter Pan I
think he was looking great until he
started looking like Voldemort no yeah
once his nose started coming off yeah
yeah that's pretty crazy if you get it
because he he got a nose job right a
million of us if you get a bunch of nose
jobs and your nose falls off that's
probably a bad doctor right yeah I know
that's why nobody's talking about his
doctor but it could have been like it
could have been like a body dysmorphia
thing like at first when it was
happening it was like all good and gravy
and then it just like you know you're
constantly unsatisfied with something as
a surgeon don't you have like a duty be
like I'm cutting you off you got a duty
to make money that's true but but have
you seen the girls that get the boobs
that are like this big yeah bro who's at
what point is the doctor going
that might be a little too big I mean if
that's what they want right is that a
hazard though no it's not a healthy it's
a plastic surgeon it's a cosmetic thing
that chick was like this big of a chest
like she can't really do anything she
can't ride a roller coaster there's
always a halfway to do something before
that um where they're like my titty is
not big enough
and it's like already like this big and
they go man I gotta get this big yeah
yeah that's the the body image thing you
know it's just more power tomb Queen
come on come on according to a report
girl was warned by the medical board she
was vital violating ethics and medical
privacy in 2018
was she ignored at least three patients
suffered severe complications under her
care including one woman whose intestine
was perforated as a result of a surgery
growth streamed on Tick Tock leading to
a blood infection and severe
complications that left her with brain
damage yo this is very specific then
it's not like it's not just because
she's streaming it's because she's
[__] up the surgery yeah the
streaming they're not too mad about it
right and who does plastic surgery
around their intestines so that's uh
yeah right they're too long
I like them a little smaller wrinkles
or maybe it's lipo yeah that's probably
just something like that and then ended
up maybe like a tummy tuck or something
yeah like she was like cutting something
and then she rests the knife on the
stomach and the knife just went ew
oh [__] pulls it out and realized she
punctured it that happened to my
friend's cat yesterday no way he rested
a knife on the cat they were cutting the
bandage off the cat and stabbed the cat
and they had to give the cat stitches
like the the veterinarian did that and
then they gave him a bill afterwards
well no they just had to explain why
there was new line of stitches on the
couch you better give me a [__]
discount dude and a lollipop
and a sticker with a [__] eyes that
could move
okay everything's okay
you did right by me but it didn't happen
it did happen before when this surgeon
just left an arm a knife in the patient
yeah they leave like all kinds of tools
and stuff in there right the surgeries
are like eight hours long sometimes yeah
so please get tired you you like
misplace your stuff sometimes exactly or
the doctor hasn't slept you know what I
mean because it's like an emergency
medical procedure and they they're the
only one that has to come in yeah I mean
the doctor was always like oh I'm in a
scissor
yeah they take naps on the floor oh [__]
oh [__] I was on autopilot for a second
I wonder if chiropractors have to go
through the same thing doubt it but they
cracked the wrong arm or something no
because you know a lot of them do
content oh yeah they crack like a lot of
chiropractors do online content where
they stream or they make videos while
they're doing I'm assuming in those ones
though because it's not like surgery
they're already getting some sort of
like signed consent from the
you know what I mean it's non-medical
well I mean at that point they're
putting a [__] microphone on that
person to get like the ASMR version of
it you know so and they're not putting
you under I think yeah that's a big
difference I think like putting you
under and then recording you there's got
to be some sort of privacy laws there
and also do you want a surgeon that's
like too busy being an influencer yeah
what if she's like doing Tick Tock
videos and [__] she goes I gotta do that
over again and you know how like when
you're recording you lose track of time
and you're in the zone and she goes man
that was a [__] hot ass take I love
that and she goes oh [__] damn the
anesthesia is wearing off oh [__]
they're waking up and you wake up ah
[__] my guts and everything oh that
could happen if I go to a surgeon and I
see a tripod in their office I'm leaving
selfie light yeah that would be a good
rule didn't they have to didn't some
hospitals have to tell nurses they
couldn't shoot tick tocks in the [__]
Hospital anymore bro those are terrible
tick tocks too everybody's got a
drinking dude you know some people got
to work their day jobs while they try to
do to entertainment and sometimes they
try to blend both like this guy yeah
yeah and I and I vlogged at the
warehouse too when I was working
yep I would hide behind the boxes and
[__] Vlog yeah we didn't miss ship
anything and you weren't responding for
someone else's safety were you I had my
co-workers recording me did you give
anybody brain damage huh did you give
anybody brain damage while you're
filming no thankfully I didn't really
risk I didn't do anything stupid I think
you're clear I think you're good yeah I
think you could you could continue to
film and Vlog in a warehouse
unlike this person this person should be
let go from their job is that so bad if
you get your license taken away from
like just Ohio you just gotta go to a
different state babe that is wild like
you have to move yeah but a state like
Ohio has States closer to it than like I
don't know like a different state I mean
what if there's states that need doctors
and they're just like well we'll take an
Ohio reject yeah we'll take it we'll
take it well I wonder if it like puts
things
because what if what if it's like maybe
you can work but
as a doctor not a surgeon a general
practitioner oh yeah so it's like they
could administer medicine because you
got like a little bit of flu and she
could live stream that that's good
content that's fine I feel like if you
work in plastic surgery someone's gonna
want you yeah for sure because I think
it's a big well I'm sure it's a big
money maker right so some Hospital might
be like I mean there's people willing to
pay for jobs from people that are not
doctors really like people that want
like uh what's it called fortune teller
or no I mean no I mean like people are
going to get butt injections from just
regular dudes that are not even medical
practitioners go with the needle Oh you
mean when assassins can't go to the
[__] hospital so they got to go to
get a vet that's cool
that's a cool job Mafia doctor right but
they're always the best though she
becomes like one of those face changing
people like if you get caught for a
crime I could turn you into it I can
[__] your face up what I don't like
about it though are the hours are
probably not flexible oh yeah because
they're like 4am hey I just got shot and
it's hot oh my God I'm not even an
emergency doctor did you get paid in
cash which is like tax-free so there's
like a you know and after you do it long
enough then you always know 4 AM is the
prime shot time
usually happen at 4 P.M you know no yeah
I'd rather just be the doctor for the
mafia so they'll be like dog I don't I
got this this is a covet Doc and I'm
like nah don't worry about it here take
some antibiotics but then if you're
wrong you're gonna get your whole family
murdered with your legs broke yeah
oh man I just want to give NyQuil how
about that yeah NyQuil is a better bet I
think I think there's uh apparently also
other like nationally reported horror
stories about lapses in medical ethics
going on around this time as well for
example uh last year a doctor in
Missouri misery Missouri was sentenced
to prison for fraud after buying up
unapproved Cut Rate drugs from overseas
for osteoarthritis injections building
the full price and pocketing the
difference to fund his lavish lifestyle
and that's why I don't go to the
hospital well when you go to the
hospital enough times you realize just
like any profession that like
some of these people are just not good
at their job at all that's like that's
the word bro when you're so scared when
you have friends that were total like uh
idiots growing up and they now work in
the hospital and they tell you that
they're [__] up that's how you know
yeah oh yeah dude when they used to let
me volunteer at the Huntington Hospital
and I would discharge patients and I
would like get lost on the hospital in
like my first couple weeks and I have a
guy who's in a wheelchair and his leg is
broken in a cast
and I accidentally like hit a wall like
I'm like dude you're gonna let me
discharge this guy this is crazy this is
irresponsible hey can you push them out
and you ran his leg into the wall I
actually hit it yeah it was a little bit
he was fine he took like a champ but
after that I go okay this is this is all
kind of nonsense this is all nonsense
everything's an illusion yeah everything
is man let's do volunteer for four hours
you get a free lunch yeah you get the
cafeteria hits yeah great great
cafeteria
foreign
[Music]